[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
rezept was ich eigentlich schon sehr
lange machen wollte und zwar pudding
besetzung
das sind die sich jetzt kennt ihr
vielleicht auch vom bag entschied ja ich
habe justin kommt sony komisch vor ich
hab' ich sehe diese konstellation zu
machen das heißt doch schon mal gemacht
und die habe ich noch nie gepackt ich
zum ersten mal
da mag es vielleicht mein exfreund meter
durch eine ex freundin ja nein warum
auch immer noch klappen aber ganz
schnell egal ist was archäologen sind
googles goog us serie jedenfalls besteht
dieses gebäck aus einem plunder teig das
ist ja so im zusammenspiel aus hefeteig
und blätterteig wirklich sehr sehr
lecker und man kann auch ganz viele
abwandlungen machen und ich werde das
rezept bestimmt auch noch mal machen
ich zeige euch jetzt aber zuerst einmal
die zutaten für den pudding den muss ich
nämlich zuerst erstellen für den pudding
brauche ich 500 milliliter milch 50 grau
stärke 60 gramm zucker 1 eickel und
etwas von den extrakt für den pudding
verhöre ich jetzt alle zutaten klümpchen
frei in einem topf und lasse dann ganz
kurz aufkochen
jetzt kann ich den pudding umfüllen in
ein flaches gefäß und ihn dann direkt
mit frischhaltefolie abdecken damit sie
keine haut bildet und so las ich in ein
komplett abkühlen und zeigt euch schon
mal die zutaten für den hefeteig bzw für
den plunder teig
[Musik]
für den teig brauche ich einen halben
würfel hefe das in 21 gramm 30 zucker
einen esslöffel wasser 130 milliliter
milch 2 ist löffel joghurt 35
prozentiger ein eigelb hier habe ich 380
gramm mehl einen halben teelöffel salz
und vanille extrakt ich führe jetzt
zuerst einmal den zucker gemeinsam mit
der hefe und dem wasser die zutaten gebe
ich jetzt in der küchenmaschine aber wir
können den teig auch ganz einfach mit
der hand verkneten
da kommt jetzt die milch dazu dann auch
der joghurt das vanille extrakt salz und
natürlich auch das mehl und jetzt kann
ich daraus in etwa fünf bis sieben
minuten einen geschmeidigen teig kneten
jetzt habe ich einen richtig schönen
geschmeidigen hefeteig der auch nicht
klebt und der muss jetzt nicht aufgehen
da wird gleich weiter verarbeitet denn
das soll ja ein blonder teig werden dh
100 tage ist einfach eine zusammen
mischung oder ein zusammenspiel aus
hefeteig und blätterteig das heißt hier
kommen jetzt butter schichten rein und
ich habe ca 160 gramm weiche butter und
kann jetzt erstmal den teig ausrollen
und zwar zu einem großen rechteck
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich ein großes rechteck vor
mir liegen jetzt nämlich die butter und
teil jetzt in vier portionen 1 das heißt
es geht ganz einfach und ist nämlich ein
viertel davon und es kommt jetzt hier
auf die rechte seite und jetzt streiche
ich hier langsam rein und zentimeter
rand frei jetzt entstehen so diese
einzelnen butter schichten und zwar
glaube ich jetzt diese seite zur mitte
dann schön drücken damit die butter
verschlossen wird dann die linke seite
drüber jetzt habe ich ein großes
rechteck welches jetzt in
frischhaltefolie gewickelt und für zehn
minuten eingefroren wird und ich hab ich
ja noch mal drei teile butter das heißt
das ganze mache ich dann gleich noch
drei mal
ab in den gefrierschrank
[Musik]
nach der vierten tor könnt ihr den teig
dann komplett ausrollen und jetzt werde
ich ihnen in zwölf streifen zu schneiden
ich habe ihn jetzt etwa auf 24
zentimeter breit ausgerollt das heißt
jeder streifen hat etwa 2 cm jetzt
nämlich einen streifen und zwiebel denen
das heißt beide enden dreht ihr in die
jeweils andere richtung und daraus wird
jetzt eine brezel geformt
[Musik]
jetzt sind die brezeln geformt die sie
ein bisschen anders aus als die
laugenbrezeln dem man kennt hier macht
man nämlich nur zwei öffnungen rein
wegen dem pudding und dem putting habe
ich jetzt bereits nach dem abkühlen
einfach durch ein feines haar sieht
gestrichen und noch mal durchgeführt das
habe ich ihnen einem spritzbeutel mit
einer großen stern spiele und kassierte
löcher damit 5
[Musik]
und bevor ich dir jetzt packe kann ich
es jetzt abdecken mit etwas frisch
alufolie und lasst ihr einfach 30
minuten aufgehen jetzt könnt ihr die
pudding paetzel mit etwas eiweiß
bestreichen und nach belieben mit den
mandeln bestreuen und dann werden sie
schon gebacken
[Musik]
die pudding brezeln sind gebacken und
ich habe ich hier einen bus gemacht aus
puderzucker und zitronensaft und den
kann ich jetzt einfach hier darüber
träufeln
[Musik]
lieber morath jetzt darfst du probieren
ich mag das geld nicht da ist es ein
bisschen weiß ja was gestrichen
ich habe so eine packung für dich okay
also tommy so sieht es auch cool ich
probiere ich stelle mich das nicht so
leer da stehen und als muss diese
teigschichten zeigen ich habe mir so
viel möglich sagt sie und zwei den
touren sie sich noch mit dem ist kein
bäcker besuchen
also ich keinen wecker vielleicht also
wenn man backwaren kauft dann gebe ich
zum handwerksbäcker aber das schafft
kein handwerk stringer er wirklich mit
vielen liefert es ist so knusprig und da
extrem einfach wahnsinn
es ist gut mal wieder probieren sondern
besser mit schoko oder so war er auch
bot genug alles komisch eigentlich und
seine zuschauer für eben vorkommen wenn
ich es immer und hat fast alles
beschränkt ist auch zwei vegane sich
gehört
ich nehme jetzt mal ganz hd putin brezel
und geht zum tisch denn das team möchte
auch gerne probieren und falls er das
rezept nach machen wollt dann schaut
auch sallys - block der etat sieht man
uns noch mal ganz genau ich wünsche euch
viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal ist populistisch ich habe
ja man sieht das ja nicht die darf nicht
[Musik]